car la question qui tue l'un
il ya venue à dijon non est-ce que vous
avez jamais regretté cette opération
jamais jamais non non je suis très
heureuse et pour rien au monde je me
souviens quand je suis rentrée à la
clinique
je me suis dit mais tu étais sûr qu
est-ce que c'est en train de faire parce
qu'il fallait vraiment faire confiance
c'est un axiome état parce que le fait
que je fasse un métier public et bon
c'était c'était assez dangereux quand
même et j'ai eu confuse et la fois comme
je lai souvent dans ma vie et je me suis
dit j'y vais je pense que c'est quelque
chose de bien pour moi quant à lui
la pression qui plus est elle est là